bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 7 avril l'otan poursuit ses
frappes aériennes sans répit et de plus
en plus violente à belgrade et pristina
mais aussi au monténégro tout le
président de cette république intégré
dans la fédération du yougoslave a reçu
notre envoyé spécial maryse burgot les
serbes ont fermé les frontières avec
l'albanie nous retrouverons benoît
duquesne sur place ainsi que jérôme
venir macédoine pour nous expliquer
comment des milliers de réfugiés du camp
de blatche et ont été déplacées pendant
la nuit
d'autres réfugiés kosovars sont contre
leur gré en turquie depuis hier
reportage dans un camp avec olivier
galzi en france ses premiers réfugiés
kosovars de briançon ont été contrôlés
par la police d'autres sont attendus
dans des centres d'accueil une histoire
enfin celle d'une jeune albanaise sorti
in extremis du kosovo pour une greffe de
moelle osseuse en france greffe donné
par son frère à militants de l'ofce
qu'un
l'actualité également l'organisation
mondial du commerce condamne l'europe
pour son système d'implantation de
bananes et donne raison à la plainte
américaine
deux militants nationalistes corses
condamné à de la prison ferme pour avoir
tiré des coups de feu et agressé des
gendarmes le 14 mars ce dernier et puis
cinéma sorti sur les écrans aujourd'hui
du film de jacques doillon petit frère
pas de répit ni d'états d'âme pour
l'otan qui a multiplié les frappes sans
tenir compte de l' annonce faite hier
par les autorités de belgrade d'un
cessez le feu unilatéral au kosovo les
bombardements ont visé belgrade et
pristina mais aussi pour la première
fois des unités de blindés commentaires
françois corner
christina au kosovo la nuit dernière
touchée par trois vagues successives de
bombardements leur est le plus massif a
eu lieu vers 0 h 45 une vingtaine de
missiles et de roquettes se sont
abattues sur le centre ville
détruisant plusieurs bâtiments
administratifs mais aussi des immeubles
d'habitation et une centaine de magasins
d'après les constatations du
correspondant de l'agencé france presse
sur place les sauveteurs auraient
jusqu'à présent retiré des décombres une
dizaine de victimes selon la police
serbe information relayée par la
télévision de belgrade dans un rayon de
300 mètres d'autres bâtiments dont ceux
du gouvernement provisoire certes de la
province de la municipalité et d'une
filiale de la banque nationale ont été
gravement endommagés un dépôt de
carburant à la périphérie de pristina a
également été touché
les chasseurs bombardiers des collants
d'aviano en italie pour la 14e nuit
consécutive ont également pris pour
cible cette raffinerie est ce dépôt de
carburant à novi sad au nord de la
serbie
d'autres objectifs ont également été
touchés des usines chimiques ou
d'explosifs des aéroports militaires et
des centres industriels comme celui de
nietzsche que nous allons voir sur ces
images tournées la nuit dernière par la
télévision serbe au petit jour l'étendue
des dégâts dans cette zone industrielle
de niche apporte la preuve de
l'efficacité de ces nouvelles frappes
qualifié de stratégique par l'otan un
début de polémique toutefois dans ces
raids de la nuit dernière ce missile
dont la télévision sert nous montre les
débris s'est abattue sur la petite
république du monténégro dont le
président milo djukanovic est un
opposant de slobodan milosevic
c'est un geste d'autodéfense dit
aujourd'hui l'otan nous avons tiré sur
une batterie de missiles antiaériens
prix menacer nos avions
que nous n'avons pas
ces derniers jours
optez pour des cibles au menu mais si
bien sûr comme c'était le cas hier soir
un de nos avions et menacer et pas une
missile sol air nos moyens à partir du
territoire monténégrins nous allons
riposter pour assurer la défense qui
pilote c'était le cas hier soir après
cette 14e nuit de bombardement tous les
avions de l'alliance sont rentrés sans
dommage sur leur bave
et selon les dirigeants serbes il aurait
eu douze civils tués après stinat où il
ya de nombreux dégâts matériels
depuis washington le président américain
a réitéré les conditions d'un arrêt des
bombardements reprenant ainsi ce que
disait hier monsieur jacques chirac sur
l'insuffisance du cessez-le-feu décrété
par belgrade de plus aujourd'hui le
secrétaire américain à la défense
monsieur william cohen était au siège de
l'otan à bruxelles reportage dans marqué
12 et olivier four niant
la guerre vue d'un sweat oeil c'est
toujours le même rituel du briefing de
15h au siège de l'otan à bruxelles la
stratégie se durcit elle évolue et avec
l'amélioration de la météo le
porte-parole rendez compte aujourd'hui
d'une première avec ce dessin et non pas
des images du premier convoi blindé
détruit en mouvement au kosovo sur 28
cible atteinte hier dont ses tanks 3 mx
supplémentaires détruits au sol à la
télévision serbe de fournir les images
de la guerre vue du sol sauf aurait
chevaux bien sûr
mais l'essentiel aujourd'hui se passera
en coulisses avec ce matin l'arrivée de
short au vote numéro deux du département
d'état retour de mission dans les pays
riverains du conflit de l'albanie à la
grèce
également l'escale à bruxelles sur le
chemin de la base d'aviano le secrétaire
américain à la défense william cohen
venu regarder les choses de près avec
toujours les trois mêmes messages nous
combattrons aussi longtemps qu'il ne
faudra pas d'intervention terrestre un
dj nous sommes malgré nos différends en
contact constant avec les russes aussi à
bruxelles aujourd'hui le ministre
britannique de la défense slogan
personne ne sera guère plus bavard il se
bornera à souligner qu' hier soir les 19
pays de l'alliance ans ont su réagir
d'une seule voix ou manoeuvre je cite de
slobodan milosevic
d'une seule voix jean marc il use mais
la cohésion de l'alliance de temps en
temps donne des signes de faiblesse
disons que quand on forme une alliance à
19 et surtout quand il s'agit de faire
la guerre les choses ne sont jamais très
facile mais si hier soir slobodan
milosevic a espéré ressusciter les
divergences de l'alliance et bien disons
que les choses n'ont pas marché vous
avez vu à londres comme à washington à
paris comme à bonn cette fois là les
disons-le est ce qu'on peut appeler les
fausses concessions de belgrade non plus
fait vaciller comme ailleurs en bosnie
la détermination de l'alliance alors
restez l'italie on s'interrogeait vous
savez que l'italie et dirigée par une
coalition très fragile à laquelle
participent des communistes qui sont
très vivement opposée aux frappes de
l'otan oui mais l'italie est aussi
géographiquement en première ligne face
aux balkans et finalement l'italie a
suivi
restez donc surtout la grèce la grèce
orthodoxe il faut savoir que la part qu
knox est extrêmement sacré pour le monde
orthodoxe un monde où la religion et la
nation sont des notions qui sont
extrêmement liés et donc il n'est pas
facile à tout ministre a tout premier
ministre grec quel qu'il soit de faire
accepter à ses concitoyens que la
coalition à laquelle appartient son
gouvernement bombardent des
coreligionnaires ben si rld en
l'occurrence mais finalement étant donné
l'importance des enjeux pour l'avenir de
l'europe la détermination l'aura emporté
sur tout le reste merci jean marc et
puis préparation sur la base des fign en
allemagne d'hélicoptère américain apache
cci kopter antichar à mach site
actuellement préparée sur ces bases
américaines on sait qu'il faut un délai
technique de plusieurs jours avant qu'il
ne soit opérationnel les etats unis
comptent déployer dans le nord de
l'albanie 24 hélicoptères que l'on voit
ici sur cette base il shine 24
hélicoptères ah-64 apache on les
surnomme tueur de chars et puis lui revu
également un bataillon d'infanterie qui
sera d'artillerie qui sera déployé en
albanie l'armée de l'air française avec
des avions jaguar et super étendard
participent activement aux frappes de
l'otan 50 avions sont déclarés
opérationnels par la france beaucoup
d'entre eux sont déployés à istres anna
près de venise où nous retrouvons nos
envoyés spéciaux alain de chalvron et
dominique merlin
12h45 ce matin si jaguar français
rentrent sur la base d'istres ana il
avait décollé vers 9 heures ont donc
passé près de quatre heures en l'air
accompagné par un groupe aérien
important entre 30 et 50 avions de
toutes les nationalités
ravitailleurs awacs appareils de
commandement de brouillage électronique
intercepteurs et cetera leur mission a
eu les jaguars et l' attaque au sol
cette mission a été soigneusement
préparée toute la nuit on leur a donné
un créneau extrêmement précis pour
frapper entre deux autres attaques un
créneau de quelques minutes où tout se
joue
quand vous avez sur l'objectif c'est
très courtois vous avez juste le temps
de reconnaître de le désigner et de
pouvoir le traiter avec les moyens qu'on
a on fait des tirs avec une précision
métrique donc ce que vous avez vu là en
fait c'est qu'il ya un avion qui
illumine avec son pote de laser il ya un
autre avion à côté qui lancent des
bombes qui elles sont guidées par cette
tache laser qui sur l'objectif à peine
arrivés les jaguars sont aussitôt
réviser des charges et des films qui
témoignent de la mission accomplie et
surtout réarmer une heure et quart après
leur retour ils peuvent reprendre l'air
pour ce qui est de l'opération de ce
matin les pilotes semblent satisfaits
ils ont pu larguer tous leurs
chargements et atteindre leur objectif
malgré les contraintes qu'ont leurs
impôts on assure au maximum la survie de
l'avion et bien sûr du pilote l'équipage
donc nous effectuons nous voler nos
opérations à en haute altitude
depuis le début des opérations il ya
donc quinze jours l'armée de l'air
française a effectué plus de 250 sorties
soumission en termes de nombre d'avions
engagés si l'on ajoute à ceux qui sont
ici les super étendard embarqué sur le
foch
la france est le premier contingent
européen de l'opération force déterminer
et puis à bari en italie une grande
manifestation contre les frappes de
l'otan a été organisée aujourd'hui on
parle de plusieurs milliers peut-être
quarante mille personnes hier il y avait
eu 150 mille manifestants également en
allemagne contre les frappes de l'otan
barry est un lieu qui rassemble
également des camps de réfugiés kosovars
c'est le lieu d'où partent des bateaux
d'aidé humanitaire vers l'albanie pour l
image de cette manifestation qui a lieu
cet après midi à bari en italie l'un des
ministres servent ayant déclaré que les
trois soldat américain capturé par les
forces yougoslaves pourrait être libéré
une information non vérifiée fait état
d'une possibilité de remise de ces trois
zones aux autorités chypriotes grecques
et le président de chypre monsieur
kyprianou espère cette libération pour
les prochaines 24 heures mais les états
unis vont dissuader de se rendre à
belgrade les frappes de l'otan n'ont pas
seulement touché des objectifs en serbie
et au kosovo mais également au
monténégro c'est la première fois depuis
huit jours car ce pays fait partie de la
république fédérale de yougoslavie mais
il tente de préserver une indépendance
de vue et d'action politique ainsi le
président du monténégro monsieur milo
djukanovic qui est âgé de 36 ans dénonce
la politique du pire de ce club aux ânes
milosevic pour france 2 maryse burgot et
gilles jacquier ont obtenu un entretien
avec le président du monténégro c'était
hier soir
hier soir vers 23 heures le président de
la république du monténégro nous reçoit
dans son bureau
il est souriant son premier ministre
aussi pourtant cet homme est toujours
dit menacé par un peu d'étapes que
préparait le leader serbe milosevic à
milo djukanovic vient de sortir d'une
réunion de crise avec son cabinet la
petite république qu'il dirige fait
partie intégrante de la yougoslavie
mais sa politique d'ouverture à
l'occident déplaise à milosevic ce
président n'est donc pas surpris par ces
rumeurs persistantes de coup d'état
fomenté contre lui
tout cela ne me surprend pas
depuis que j'ai été élu président de la
république du monténégro
c'est à dire depuis octobre 1997
monsieur milosevic je pense et développe
en permanence des plans pour renverser
de force le pouvoir actuel dans notre
république
il cherche comment mettre le monténégro
sous la coupe de son régime autocratique
cela veut dire et tout fait la
démocratie qui a commencé au monténégro
et il a raison d'avoir sérieusement peur
que notre démocratie ne déborde nos
frontières et s'étendent sur toute la
yougoslavie
mais aujourd'hui le monténégro est prêt
à défendre son état sa dignité sa
démocratie qui est une épine dans l'oeil
de millau série choco
pendant que nous interviewons milo
djukanovic
à l'extérieur du palais les forces de
police loyales au président garde les
lieux ses hommes feront tout pour sauver
la naissante démocratie monténégrin pour
eux comme pour leurs jeunes président
milosevic est un dictateur qu'il faut
combattre
tous les jours en lui je vois son désir
de destruction
sa volonté d' à genouillé le monténégro
dans la fédération yougoslave
je vois sa volonté de désavouer le
pouvoir issu des urnes au monténégro
et tout cela fait que la communauté
yougoslavie aujourd'hui ces moments les
plus difficiles depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale
ces moments difficiles
les monténégrins les vifs effectivement
quotidiennement cette nuit le souffle de
l'explosion d'un missile à podgorica la
capitale a provoqué quelques dégâts
matériels rien de comparable évidemment
aux bombardements suivi un ferme mais la
population comme son président trouve
ses frappes particulièrement injuste
il faut que milosevic obtempère mais il
faut aussi que l'otan arrête ses
bombardements sur la yougoslavie
parce que c'est évident que ces bombes
sur la fédération ne sont une solution
ni pour la paix au kosovo ni pour la
stabilité dans la région
les bombes envoyées par l'otan sur le
premier gros ont pour effet de
radicaliser la population
cette manifestation pro milosevic que
nous avons filmé ce soir à podgorica
rassembler plusieurs milliers de
personnes ceux qui participaient à cet
événement ne soutiennent et évidemment
pas le président jacques anouma
mais la question est de savoir s'ils
seront demain suffisamment nombreux pour
aider milosevic à reprendre ici le
pouvoir
maryse burgot en regardant votre
reportage on comprend bien que les
bombarde monde pour première conséquence
de déstabiliser de fragiliser le régime
du monténégro
oui c'est vrai qu'il ya ici depuis
plusieurs jours des rumeurs persistantes
de coup d'état ces informations sont
évidemment invérifiable
ce que je peux vous dire tout de même
c'est que la tension est montée d'un
cran ici aujourd'hui avec ces nouvelles
frappes de l'otan cette nuit l'otan dit
ce soir qui est que cette organisation
n'a fait que répondre à des attaques de
l'armée ou le gougaud slave mais les
faits sont là la petite république du
monténégro a été à nouveau bombardée et
la population se radicalise l'otan avait
pourtant promis d'éviter de bombarder
cette petite république pour ne pas
gêner l'actuel président du canot vite
ce président que vous avez vues dans le
reportage djukanovic qui a tout de même
une attitude assez courageuse puisqu'il
s'oppose à milosevic et en ce moment ce
président démocrate est plutôt assez
gêné par l'attitude de l'otan merci
maryse les autorités serbes ont décidé
de fermer leurs frontières aux réfugiés
kosovars désireux de se rendre notamment
en albanie les deux principaux postes
frontière morina et café pro che ont été
fermées par l'armée morina le plus
important était celui par lequel les
réfugiés que sauveur fuyant les
massacres des exactions serbe affluaient
depuis le 27 mars en albanie reportage
sur cette frontière avec benoît duquesne
et didier dame
le contraste en jour 250 mille personnes
sont passées ici un flot ininterrompu de
souffrance et de drames dont une
humanité jeter dans la tourmente et la
guerre et tout à coup plus rien que le
vent et la tente ne reste ici que les
traces de cette fuite éperdue que les
souvenirs de cette déportation et
quelques vigiles humanitaire qui se
tiennent prêtes au kazoo
alors on attend jusqu'à l'endormissement
le bon vouloir de milosevic
vous êtes du hrc
vous pouvez nous dire ce qui se passe
ici
est bien la frontière est fermée depuis
3h ce matin
et depuis lors le flux des réfugiés
s'est arrêté
comment pouvez vous expliquer cela
c'est pas très bien quelles sont les
raisons de cet arrêt
est mais apparemment c'est une décision
des autorités serbes
même le député local du parti de berisha
se perd en conjectures
une nouvelle stratégie
de milosevic
tôt ce matin dans les camps près de la
ville on était loin des spéculations sur
la stratégie milosevic parce qu'ils ont
été chassés de chez eux parce que leur
maison était brûlé leurs papiers et
leurs biens confisqués leurs proches
tués il savait depuis longtemps qu'avec
le boucher de belgrade comme il
l'appelle le pire est toujours sûr
nous avons l'habitude de ce genre de
déclarations des serbes on a déjà vu ce
que ça donnait en bosnie en slovénie en
croatie et maintenant
le monde entier sait bien que les serres
ne tiennent pas leur parole
ce que nous espérons c'est une
intervention étrangère une intervention
terrestre houston le chauffard c'en est
fini du kosovo
la théorie d'un kosovo la descendance de
la serbie
c'est trop tard situation est allé bien
trop loin
et parle maintenant d'un abandon
alors pour eux la préoccupation
principale c'est maintenant la route
l'exode en attendant l'otan et le retour
alors ce soir benoît duquesne que pouvez
vous constatez près de la frontière
les côtés il ya plusieurs choses d'abord
en ce qui concerne les réfugiés
l'annnonce de la redd ce flou et tac 8
façon assez mitigée par les ambitions
militaires d'abord parce qu'elles sont
relativement content de pouvoir un peu
mieux gérer les 250 300 mille personnes
qui se trouvent déjà eu ici en albanie
et puis elle s'inquiète aussi du sort
des kosovars qui sont restés bloqués de
l'autre côté le sont ils contre leur gré
est ce que par exemple le service n'a
pas changé de stratégie en pensant qu'il
était peut être bon mais garder avec lui
comme boucliers humains au kosovo et
puis il ya cette ambiance très
particulière à la frontière vous l'avez
vu il faisait très très beau cet après
midi la route était à nouveau déserte et
en s'y rendant et j'en ai presque
l'impression se retrouve en vacances et
puis en arrivant on voit quand même la
frontière on voit quand même que
d'autres d'autre côté les seules
activités notable des serbes sont des
travaux de terrassement vois qu'ici en
ville sept ou huit camions chargés de
fonds spécial albanaise traverse la vie
nous on apprend que le secrétaire
général adjoint de l'otan passe ici ce
matin pour confirmer l'arrivée prochaine
des 6000 hommes de l'otan non loin d'ici
à 5 10 minutes en hélicoptère et
l'installation peut-être ici d'un
quartier général on apprend que le
parlement albanais accepte l'arrivée
très hommes qu'aussitôt belgrade décide
que deux fêtes l'albanie se trouve en
gare en guerre contre la serbie alors
tout cela fait réfléchir et puis on
s'interroge on se dit bon où on n'est ni
assez vite parce qu'il est en train de
fléchir est ce que les frappes sur le
kosovo l'on fait un petit peu réfléchir
ou bien ce que pour traire il prépare à
autre chose et danse la danse eux dans
ce cas goy ce sont les questions qui se
posent ici merci benoît le sort des
milliers de réfugiés du camp de blatche
et que nous vous montrions hier en
macédoine est particulièrement difficile
à cerner aujourd'hui depuis hier soir
quatorze mille réfugiés de ce camp
souvent comparé un cloaque
invraisemblable de misère et d'absence
de soins sont entrés en allemagne et ce
matin ce camp de blatche était
totalement vide il y a dix jours vingt
mille personnes s'y trouvaient et il
faut bien utiliser le mot de déportation
précipité nocturne à propos de ce camp
de black reportage germany et andreï
sera
le camp improvisé de blatche et sur la
frontière entre la macédoine et le
kosovo vis des du jour au lendemain de
ces derniers réfugiés un champ de toiles
et de bâches qui n'est plus qu'un
mauvais souvenir
une étape dans l'exode des habitants de
pristina la capitale du kosovo
le poste frontière est maintenant lui
aussi désert les réfugiés bloqués de
l'autre côté par les serbes ont dû
retourner à christina
48 heures d'évacuation jour et nuit pour
vider ce vallon de ses occupants de gré
ou de force 360 car pour des dizaines de
milliers d'exilés sous le contrôle de
l'armée macédonienne tous rêvent de
retourner chez eux mais chacun sait que
ce rêve cette nuit s'est éloigné de
centaines ou même de milliers de
kilomètres certains vont se retrouver à
l'étranger les plus chanceux vont rester
en macédoine la représentante ici du
haut commissariat aux réfugiés pour la
ghedini vient de faire part au
gouvernement macédonien de sa
préoccupation
si l'évacuation précipitée aboutissent à
des séparations de famille en fin
d'après-midi une poignée de réfugiés se
trouvaient encore dans le camp de
blattes ces derniers carrés de
résistance aux évacuations macédonienne
d'un côté et serbes de l'autre
des responsables de l'association
française action contre la faim était ce
soir dans un camp installé par les
français à dix minutes de là pour
constater le désastre ils n'ont eu aucun
choix pour arriver ici ils n'ont eu
aucun choix pour être transférés dans
des autobus dans des camps et là hier on
a amené quelques avec des autobus
quelques-uns sur l'albanie d'autres en
turquie mais sans leur laisser le choix
ils ont aucun choix c'est pour ça que je
vis sont pas des réfugiés qui peuvent
choisir où ils vont se réfugier ce sont
des déportés qui sont manipulés bon par
les autorités de l'endroit où ils sont
ils sont donc dans une situation assez
désespérée
les organisations internationales et les
associations font de leur mieux pour
soulager au jour le jour la détresse de
ces albanais du kosovo
ge money kovic l'un des camps de
réfugiés installés par les forces de
l'otan quelle est la situation ce soir
est bien ici effectivement sont arrivés
tous ces réfugiés beaucoup d'ailleurs de
blatche et l'endroit que nous venons de
voir ce sont tous des indésirables pour
les autorités macédoniennes et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il ya eu une
certaine précipitation dans ces
évacuations mais ici dans le camp de
braizat qui a été organisée par l'otan
par les anglais et les français
notamment il y a de 20 à 30000 personnes
le problème de cette précipitation dans
l'évacuation des réfugiés parce que les
autorités macédoniennes ne voulait
surtout pas qu'ils restent en macédoine
c'est qu'il ya des séparations des
familles et le haut commissariat aux
réfugiés nous donner l'exemple d'une
femme qui est dans ce camp ici et qui a
eu au téléphone par chance car il ya une
association qui aide les gens à
téléphoner qui a eu au téléphone son
fils qui lui et se trouvait en turquie
alors c c'est ce genre de drames que les
associations et le haut commissariat aux
réfugiés voulait absolument éviter pour
que au moins ces réfugiés dans leur
détresse puisse rester en famille mais
il ya tout de même une note d'espoir qui
nous a été donnée par le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés qui a eu un
contact avec christina ou à réfugiés est
retourné chez lui et semble-t-il veut
rester là bas c'est c'est un cas assez
rare mais il ya une note d'espoir tout
de même semble-t-il ce soir qu'un
certain nombre de réfugiés puissent
retourner à pristina ayant kosovo c'est
un gros point d'interrogation ne sais
pas ce qui se passe là bas mais c'est en
tout cas la volonté de tous ces réfugiés
qui ne veulent pas être conduit à
l'étranger qui ne veulent pas être
conduit dans un corridor de déviation
comme voulait le faire le président
gligorov vers l'albanie ya 14000 qui
sont allés en albanie mais la plupart
veulent pour l'instant rester ici
laisser la chance au temps pour pouvoir
éventuellement rentrer chez eux merci
jérôme plusieurs camps sont en effet
organisées en macédoine par différents
pays membres de l'otan valérie fonio et
frédéric basket ont pu visiter celui mis
en place par les forces armées
italiennes
une halte de plus frères de sang et
d'errance ils ont échoué cette nuit dans
ce camp de stankovic plage dans le
convoi qui les amenés ici c'est d'abord
arrêté dans le camp tenu par des
français mais faute de place ils ont dû
les refouler le transfert ne s'est pas
fait sans ménagement mais tout cela ne
les étonne plus quand nous avons évacué
pour passer la frontière et venir ici la
police macédonienne a battu des enfants
et des mamans des enfants vous comprenez
c'est plus facile les militaires
italiens qui gère le camp n'ont pas
encore eu le temps de donner un abri à
cette famille comme ou centaines
d'autres arrivés cette nuit c'est
seulement en fin d'après midi que chacun
recevait son lot couvertures nourriture
et eau les tentes n'arriveront que
demain mais peu importe pour eux c'est
toujours mieux que l'enfer du camp de
blatche est situé entre les deux postes
frontières
bien sûr qu'on est mieux ici que là-bas
là bas c'était infernal mais je suis là
depuis deux jours et je n'ai toujours
pas pris de douche cela fait huit jours
que je n'ai pas pris de douche
des candidats au départ il y en a eu
encore beaucoup aujourd'hui destination
l'allemagne la finlande quelques places
seulement 400 au total
le sort des réfugiés du kosovo dépend à
présent des forces de l'alliance des
forces françaises allemandes anglaises
et italiennes qui gère les sept camps
présents ici en macédoine des forces
d'interposition qui font tout pour que
les réfugiés restent ici même s'ils
organisent des vols pour rejoindre les
pays d'accueil la coordination de l'aide
humanitaire internationale que ce var
est assurée par le haut commissariat de
l'onu pour les réfugiés le hcr madame
ogata qui le haut commissaire du hcr
doit se rendre sur place elle a fait
aujourd'hui un arrêt au vatican pour y
rencontrer le pape jean paul ii on à
moga tas s'est prononcé contre les
évacuations forcées des réfugiés du
kosovo dans des pays éloignés bonifay
fait allusion dans l'âme au gatt a
reconnu une certaine confusion dans la
gestion de la crise notamment en
macédoine quant à l'aide humanitaire
alimentaire apportée par les avions
venus de nombreux pays européens mais
aussi des états unis à les stocker en
albanie à tirana où a duré ch et quand
je dis stocker c'est un euphémisme car
on découvre jour après jour des
détournements au pire des lenteurs
administratives au mieux et
détournements et lenteurs qui handicape
sérieusement l'efficacité de l'action
humanitaire reportage bertrand cocq et
roger motte
c'est encore plus beau but et deux aides
et il n'est pas au bout de ses peines le
médecin colonel de la sécurité civile
à tirana depuis six jours le docteur
viala est chargée d'installer des camps
pour les kosovars
mais aussi de garder un oeil sur l'aide
française cet après midi il se rend dans
le port de douvres s
il est allé
français qu' aucun départ le pourra il
ya quatre jours twinair
le port de douvres s sur la grille est
en principe l'endroit est sûr gardé de
jour comme de nuit
l'aide s'entassent dans un entrepôt sous
la responsabilité du hcr
première découverte les palettes
français vont changer de place c'était
bien organisé
prévu cette mère bien carré est là mais
non
vous allez beaucoup moins
deuxième découvert une partie des
caisses a été ouverte ce sont des
disques
comme ça encore rien dire et je vérifie
au coca cola ya ce qu'il faut aucun
sommes encore pas dans la
langue des choses
c'est j'en sais rien parce que quand on
est arrivé tout était bien palettisés en
palettes bien ordonnée vous avez vu
comment c'est tout mélanger j'ai déjà
des couvertures qui manquent à priori
manque d'ouverture
mais la grande préoccupation du docteur
viala ce sont ces médicaments plusieurs
caisses aux couleurs de l'aide
humanitaire française
elles sont là derrière les boîtes de
sardines de quoi traiter
natation désinfection c'est uniquement
que des médicaments
dans le meilleur des cas ce médicament
parviendront si j'ai quand
j'espère dans le meilleur des cas qu'ils
aient pas y aurait trois jours un
exemple parmi d'autres de la pagaille
qui règne en albanie ces jours ci avec
quelques raisons d'espérer ce camion
chargé de farine partie cet après-midi
de dour s parviendra demain matin aux
réfugiés de kukes
exemples de ces transferts forcés mais
aussi de la séparation de familles de
réfugiés avec ces kosovars embarquée
plutôt de force que degrés vers la
turquie selon le ministère turc de
l'intérieur environ 2000 réfugiés du
kosovo sont déjà arrivés ils ont été
conduits dans des camps à l'ouest du
pays reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
olivier galzi et bruno livertout
la chance a voulu qu'il retrouve ses
cousins du kosovo parmi les nouveaux
réfugiés
wharton en blanc et notre interprète i
les turcs d'origine kosovare et ses
cousins du pays qu'il retrouve ici il ne
les avait pas vu depuis bien longtemps
cela fait au moins deux ans nous dit-il
peut-être même quatre ans que je ne les
avais pas vus ils sont arrivés par avion
hier
nous sommes à gaziosmanpasa un camp de
réfugiés perdu dans les confins du nord
de la turquie
aucun d'eux n'avait pourtant demandé à
venir ici
en montant dans l'avion hier ils ne nous
ont même pas dit oui nous emmener
racontera cet homme les policiers
macédonien nous ont expulsés parfois à
coups de matraques ils ont séparé
certaines familles ils nous ont traités
comme des animaux ajoutent ils et avec
le souvenir la peine remonte au fond des
yeux
la turquie de son côté essaie de faire
au mieux elle a mis à la disposition de
ses 1500 réfugiés vivres couvertures et
matelas et pour ceux qui peuvent encore
payé il ya même un téléphone seul lien
avec le monde avec leurs familles seul
moyen pour dire où ils sont et pour
repartir peut-être ailleurs vers une
destination choisie cette fois
j'appelle mon fils en slovaquie dit cet
homme je veux essayer de le rejoindre je
n'ai rien à faire ici
en attendant les plus chanceux se sont
installés dans ces préfabriqués
construit en 92 pour les réfugiés
bosniaques certains y habitent
d'ailleurs toujours
les autres les derniers arrivés n'auront
droit qu'à une tente pour eux c'est la
fin d'un long voyage le début de l'exil
tout à l'heure le premier ministre turc
est venu rendre visite aux réfugiés il
est venu leur dire qu'ils les soutenait
bien sûr est que cette situation n'était
que provisoire mais il suffit de parler
avec des bosniaques présent dans le camp
depuis 92 pour savoir que le provisoire
ici cela peut durer longtemps
parmi les autres pays de l'europe qui
est fait savoir qu'il était prêt à
accueillir des réfugiés et l'allemagne
qui a fait savoir qu'ils étaient pas
tarder à dix mille réfugiés pour
l'instant ce sont quelques dizaines
seulement qui sont arrivés à nuremberg
six vols sont prévus deux puisque
billets en macédoine
arrivé au cours de l'année prochaine
pourrait faire quelques centaines de
personnes donc transféré vers
l'allemagne
à partir de moscou un convoi de
transport routier a été mis en place
pour apporter de l'aide aux serbes et
aux habitants de belgrade de plus
bruxelles s'il a demandé que l'on ne
rejette pas l'initiative d'agresser le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
elle réaffirmait que le leader albanais
du kosovo le leader modéré ibrahim
rugova était bien livre de fait il est
toujours apprécié na mais sous la
protection entre guillemets de la police
serbe puis enfin à moscou ce soir la
duma key chambre basse du parlement
russe a adopté à une large majorité une
résolution recommandant l'envoi d'armes
en yougoslavie à luxembourg les
ministres de l'intérieur de l'union
européenne étaient rassemblés pour mieux
coordonner leur stratégie à l'égard des
réfugiés du kosovo manifestement même si
chacun est prêt à débloquer les sommes
d'argent les choix sont différents en
matière d'accueil reportage christian
mary mono les ministres de l'intérieur
sont arrivés à luxembourg avec une
intime conviction apporter une aide
appropriée aux réfugiés du kosovo mais
les quinze avaient une approche
différente
l'allemagne était prête à accueillir dix
mille réfugiés ge est partagé par
l'autriche et la suède d'autres pays
n'ont pas voulu s'engager sur les
contingents l'accueil se fera au cas par
cas il faut en revanche accroître l'aide
à l'albanie et à la macédoine la france
a été rejointe par la grande-bretagne
l'italie et l'espagne pas question de
fixer des quotas ce serait un message
désastreux
la france a une mission humanitaire il a
une tradition d'accueil mais elle ne
s'engage pas dans une politique de
quotas parce qu'elle est contraire à
l'objectif politique que je crois aussi
contraire à l'intérêt des familles
l'aide aux réfugiés étaient les missions
essentielles des ministres de
l'intérieur demain les ministres des
affaires étrangères recevant leurs
homologues des pays proches du kosovo
pour évoquer la question clé la
stabilité régionale et qui passe par une
aide économique très importante à
londres le secrétaire d'état aux
affaires étrangères monsieur robin cook
a reçu publiquement le rédacteur en chef
d'un journal kosovars que l'on avait
annoncé mort durant la première semaine
des frappes de l'otan
l'angleterre veut aider la presse
indépendante yougoslave mais monsieur
cook en a profité pour attaquer
directement la famille de slobodan
milosevic actuellement en vacances en
crète reportage à londres tirée curtet
et demetrio furent clean
l'avis de décès de barton actions
avaient été publiés par zine dépendantes
c'est l'otan depuis bruxelles qui avait
annoncé sa mort
mais depuis lundi le jeune rédacteur en
chef du plus grand quotidien albanais du
kosovo est réapparu il raconte une
histoire incroyable celle en fait de
beaucoup de réfugiés
à la hausse
j'étais l'ami de monsieur kelmendi
le célèbre avocat des droits de l'homme
qui a été tué le premier jour après le
début des bombardements
j'étais dans le tribunal avec lui on
avait des informations selon lesquelles
j'étais sur la liste des gens à battre
pour cela
l'otan avait annoncé l'exécution de tous
les intellectuels qui a assisté à
l'enterrement du célèbre avocat albanais
la formation s'est avérée fausse même si
le journaliste a dû longtemps se cacher
avant de pouvoir fuir désormais elle est
à la recherche d'argent pour ouvrir un
journal et informer les réfugiés dans
leur langue l'allemagne lundi
l'angleterre aujourd'hui qui donne un
million de francs londres a tenu à
organiser une conférence de presse
en fait tout a commencé trois ou quatre
jours avant le début des bombardements
de l'otan
robin cook amène donc aux médias les
témoins de ce qui se passe au kosovo et
justifie un peu plus la position
anglaise un moment choisi aussi pour
hausser le ton vis-à-vis de slobodan
milosevic
au peuple serbe quelle fortune vous avez
extraits de séries pendant que dans le
même temps votre pays s'appauvrit
dit combien vous avez dans les banques
étrangères puisque vous contrôler ce qui
reste des médias elle grade
montré les photos des villas que vous et
votre famille au cd athènes corfou et en
crète laissez les voir le luxueux yacht
que vous gardez en grèce pendant que les
serbes font des efforts pour survivre il
est bien dans la tradition diplomatique
anglo saxon de diaboliser l'adversaire
et comme dans la crise irakienne la
personnalisation des attaques contre
slobodan milosevic présenté par londres
comme le principal obstacle à la paix
est aussi à l'appel à le renverser a
paris il n'y a pas eu de débat ce matin
en conseil des ministres concernant la
situation kosovo monsieur lionel jospin
a simplement rappelé les cinq points des
propositions françaises permettant
l'arrêt des frappes et puis je vous
annonce que le premier ministre lionel
jospin sera demain en direct l'invité de
ce journal de 20 heures à l'elysée le
président chirac a présidé un conseil
restreint sur le kosovo avec monsieur
jospin plusieurs ministres et de hauts
responsables militaires fait
exceptionnel ce conseil restreint de
défense a ouvert ses portes un instant
aux caméras
l'accueil en france des réfugiés du
kosovo s'organise petit à petit mes
premières surprises pour 27 kosovars
sans papiers ils ont eu droit aux locaux
de la police chargée de la surveillance
de la frontière franco italienne à
montgenèvre dans les hautes-alpes
reportage jacques cardoze et vincent des
ombres voyage pour échapper aux
atrocités selon l'ars or ici c'est cette
famille aurait quitté peja une localité
proche de pristina au lendemain du début
des frappes de l'otan depuis ce 25 mars
ces 27 réfugiés auraient traversé
l'albanie la mer adriatique l'italie
toute entière de bari à montgenèvre le
poste frontière franco italien une fan
parcours qu'il aurait effectuées tous
ensemble dans un même camion de bari à
montgenèvre interpellé hier en gare de
briançon ils ont pu passer une première
nuit en france mais ne peuvent oublier
les conditions de leur départ
il
dort la mesure qu'il a dit lors de mon
père si vous désirez revoir la vôtre
faire il fait de payer 1000 10 10 mille
marque dans les rues de grosses sommes
il y à beaucoup des bleus s'est beaucoup
de ces
sons soul caisson la main
mais c'est albanais peuvent avoir
profité du conflit pour quitter une
italie qui les aurait hébergé il ya
plusieurs mois car la police soupçonne
depuis un an le passage de clandestins
ici même depuis l'italie en attendant
ceux là ont obtenu une autorisation de
séjour de trois mois
pour des motifs humanitaires il était
important qu'ils se retaper un peu donc
la ville de briançon a donné la
possibilité de les héberger de les
restaurer de leur permettre de changer
de vêtements la croix rouge est
intervenu pour apporter des vêtements et
je crois que il ya un médecin également
qu'il sera sur place pour examiner donc
la santé en particulier des enfants
loger ici dans ce centre d'oxygénation
les vingt-sept réfugiés souhaite
rejoindre l'angleterre et l'allemagne
pour des raisons familiales ils peuvent
aussi demander l'asile territoriales en
france au nom des risques vitaux
quant à l'aide humanitaire en france
elle est largement préparés par des
associations et des organisations non
gouvernementales les initiatives se
multiplient malgré parfois des lourdeurs
administratives
l'explication ilana moryoussef bernard
ronfler
affiche message radio pages spéciales
dans le journal régional la ville de
bordeaux s'est mobilisé tous médias
confondus
objectif rassembler le plus de dons
possibles pour les réfugiés kosovars une
entreprise a même prêté son standard
téléphonique pour recevoir les appels
des donateurs on a aussi reçu pas mal
d'appels de gens qui demandent qui
offrent leur maison
à lyon l'association mille enfants a
reçu 250 appels dans la journée des
familles françaises candidates pour
accueillir chez elle des réfugiés
kosovars je me suis dit oh si j'avais un
deuxième enfant je ne poserai pas de
questions je
m'adapterai pour héberger mon deuxième
enfant est bien là je dois m'adapter je
m'adapte aussi on est finalement on vous
me voyez là dans mon petit confort c'est
bien de partager on a des choses faut
les partager à ambazac près de limoges
ces jeunes se sont volontairement privé
de vacances ils vont participer à la
collecte de vivre organisée par la croix
rouge dans les supermarchés
en voyant les images de la télévision se
rendent beaucoup mieux comptez vous
faire quelque chose on se remet plus
près des gens par les masques les
militaires eux aussi sont mobilisés
soixante hommes du 1er régiment de
hussards parachutistes de tarbes ont
pris la route pour l'albanie à bord
d'une vingtaine de camions sur place
leur travail consistera exclusivement à
aider les associations humanitaires
enfin pour conclure provisoirement ce
chapitre de l'actualité consacrée à la
situation au kosovo voici maintenant
l'histoire d'une jeune femme une
albanaise du kosovo qui vient de
bénéficier d'une véritable chaîne de
solidarité
elle a pu sortir du territoire du kosovo
in extremis et rejoindre paris pour
recevoir une greffe de moelle osseuse le
donneur c'est son frère et ce garçon
militants séparatistes a dû choisir
entre la vie de sa soeur et
l'incertitude dramatique quant au sort
de sa famille récit jean daniel
flaysakier rémy poissonnier mal bonne à
17 ans et la vie ne lui a rien épargné
son village du kosovo ait été attaquée
par les serbes le 17 mars mais elle se
bat déjà depuis un an contre une
leucémie c'est un médecin français qui
lui a fait quitter le kosovo pour la
france le jour du début des frappes de
l'otan j'ai beaucoup pensé là quand les
frappes ont eu lieu et je pense que ce
serait pas resté à l'hôpital dans le
meilleur des cas alors été jeté sur les
routes et elle aurait été incapable de
rentrer par ses propres moyens pied et
donc malheureusement malgré sûrement
plus la balle bono va subir une greffe
de moelle elle a trouvé un donneur
compatible
l'un de ses sept frères opposants du
régime serbe c'est pour cela que nous
avons caché son visage ils se mettent
s'est trouvé face à un terrible choix
la vie de sa soeur ou la sécurité de sa
femme et de ses enfants
au début avec ma famille on ne
comprenait pas bien ce qui se passait sa
vie tout est arrivé brutalement
l'annnonce de la maladie puis celle du
départ je suis seul pour faire vivre
tous les miens partir c'était les
laisser sans protection et sans
nourriture associant quand on est à un
moment j'ai compris que sans moi ma
soeur était condamné alors j'ai décidé
de partir avec elle pour la france
valbuena va vivre deux mois très durs
isolé en chambre stérile une autre
chimiothérapie puis la greffe et la
tente avec son frère
je me sens mieux de le savoir près de
moi à chaud mais ça va pas chez des
monnaies sans lui je ne pourrais pas
dire
j'avais tellement peur qu'ils soient
tués en combattant
seul point noir est de taille valbuena
ne sais pas ce qui est devenu sa famille
si la paix revenait au kosovo je me
sentirais plus forte pour guérir
valbuena n'a plus qu'un seul souhait
guérir au plus vite pour entrer les
quiches maîtres chez eux au kosovo
dernière information sur cette actualité
une nouvelle alerte aérienne à belgrade
annonçant un danger de bombardements ou
l'union européenne perdu sa bataille
engagée à propos de l'importation de
bananes contre les états unis des
américains ont obtenu satisfaction
devant l'om c'est l'organisation
mondiale du commerce le système européen
est trop protectionniste au regard des
règles du libéralisme américain
c'est une décision très importante en
matière de commerce international
explication pascal golomer
le lieu est méconnu c'est pourtant ici
au siège de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce à genève que se joue d'étranges
partie de bras de fer entre géants
économiques et le vaincu du jour c'est
le roc dames condamnées pour ces règles
d'importation de bananes un accès
privilégié pour 70 pays producteurs des
caraïbes ou d'afrique sans compter les
départements d'outre-mer français des
barrières douanières importante en
revanche pour les producteurs d'amérique
latine contrôlé par les multinationales
américaines système discriminatoire
disent les états unis l'om c'est leur
donne raison l'europe doit admettre la
défaite du bout des lèvres
c'est cependant ce jury a apparemment
estimé que certains aspects de notre
système ne sont pas en conformité avec
les règles de l'omc
nous avons besoin d'étudier exactement
ce qu'il arrive nous nous réservons le
droit de faire appel l'om c'est chiffre
le préjudice subi par les états unis à
un peu plus d'un milliard de francs par
an soit trois fois moins que
l'estimation faite par les américains
des américains qui prennent ce montant
comme base de calcul pour leurs mesures
de rétorsion contre les produits
européens importés aux états unis des
jambes aux italiens aux pulls en
cachemire en passant par les fromages
français une première liste a déjà été
publié elle devra donc être réduite
reste pour l'europe a modifié son
système d'importation sans que le choc
soit trop brutal pour les producteurs de
bananes qu'elle protégeait jusqu'à lors
après la société générale c'est paribas
qui se prononce contre love [__] des
changes fait par la bnp mais le
processus continue encore à l'initiative
de la bnp le ministre de l'agriculture
jean glavany a annoncé de nouvelles
mesures de soutien aux éleveurs de porcs
près de 140 millions de francs répartis
en allègements de charges est en mesure
d' aides à la reconversion en corse à
bastia les magistrats du tribunal
correctionnel se sont montrés très
fermes à l'égard de militants
nationalistes qui avaient agressé un
capitaine de la gendarmerie de
ghisonaccia au soir du second tour des
élections territoriales
deux militants étaient poursuivis l'un
d'eux a été condamné après un délibéré
très courts à 18 mois de prison ferme
reportage pascal douce est bon et bernie
mériaux
démonstratif rené qualité l'homme est un
vieux briscard des batailles politiques
qu'elle soit musclé ou pas
ses ennuis aujourd'hui sont de l'ordre
du droit commun une triste histoire de
gifles de coups de poing et d' insulte
mais les militants nationalistes venus
le soutenir ce matin ne sont pas de cet
avis pour eux l affaire est purement
politique pour preuve l'avocat de rené
canuti n'est autre que jean guy talamoni
têtes de listes nationalistes auteur
d'un beau succès il ya trois semaines
aux élections territoriales et il y a
trois semaines à ghisonaccia dans la
plaine orientale de l'île c'était
justement pour fêter bruyamment ce
succès que des militants avaient tiré
des coups de fusil devant la gendarmerie
la tradition veut que en haye sous les
fenêtres des adversaires et les
adversaires sans doute pour ces
militants s'étaient les gendarmes cela
dit la tradition veut également que
l'adversaire et vient supporter cela et
reste enfermé chez lui mais ce soir là
le capitaine roux est sorti en civil et
sans arme pour tenter de calmer les
fêtards rené qu'un outil lui a répondu à
coups de poing et de pied
depuis son arrestation la gendarmerie de
ghisonaccia reçu d'autres visites la
semaine dernière les inconnus l'ont
mitraillé en plein jour avec du gros
calibre avant de prendre la fuite
18 mois de prison ferme pour rené canuti
six mois dont quatre avec sursis pour un
autre militant de quoi attiser les
rancoeurs dans la foule cet après midi
certains promettaient discrètement de ne
pas en rester là
sport rugby voici la composition de
l'équipe de france qui rencontrera pour
le dernier match du tournoi des cinq
nations l'ecosse samedi au stade de
france les sélectionneurs ont fait appel
au toulousain christian l'habite et aux
palois thierry cléda match retransmis
évidemment en direct samedi sur france 2
derniers retransmission en compagnie de
pierre albaladejo si les maths depuis
cet après midi sur nos écrans le film de
jacques doillon petit frère c'est le
regard porté sur des enfants de banlieue
parfois en difficulté mais toujours
plein d'imagination les acteurs des
enfants ont appris aussi à improviser
reportage à pantin sur le tournage de
petits frères avec michel mompontet et
jean-paul chaussée
qui me contre lui mais c'était bien pour
moi mais tom un petit eric woerth et
petit fils dans la vie des petits frères
c'est d'abord un territoire celui de la
cité mais plutôt couleurs gallèse
les films de doyon s'est d'abord aussi
un territoire celui de l'enfance mais
plutôt couleurs tendresse
mais le film petit frère est bien plus
qu'une histoire d'enfance dans la cité
c'est l'histoire d'une écoute
celle de doillon bien sûr pour des
gamins dont la vie hésitent encore à se
dessiner fermement entre débrouille et
délits les dérapages vécue comme une
fatalité
et tout cela donne un film bouleversant
d'authenticité
on retrouve pour chats comme ça je peux
le retrouver hier vers son poste le
chien ni france où est son corps où sont
ces bâtards que j'avais ajouté c'était
le jour ce pas d'époque le canton
retraitement la clé aucune part en ce
sens où la vie qui continue à faire sa
petite souris d'artumas déchiré tu peux
aisément les 115 ch ou par nancy s'est
pas tu attendais le meilleur d'eux donc
il savait que j'avais le meilleur d'eux
assez vite ils sont acceptés de de faire
de très gros efforts pour que
il soit qu'il y ait plus de charme ou
quand même un petit peu de magie de
temps en temps sur ce coup de grâce ou
simplement
faire avec beaucoup moins de monde parce
que la route et pré adolescents dans
l'innocence s'effiloche sur chaque jour
un peu plus sont le coeur battant de ce
film admirable
admirable d'attention mais aussi de
regard
et ce soir après le journal de la nuit
jacques doillon sera l'invité du cercle
de philippe lefait nous arrivons à la
fin de ce journal avant de le refermer
je vous rappelle la situation au kosovo
la suite des frappes aériennes encore ce
soir avec les destructions à belgrade
après sin à l'origine du monténégro
train d'être déstabilisé et puis un
certain nombre d'enseignants
d'intellectuels à belgrade ont organisé
une chaîne humaine sur le pont pour
défier des frappes de l'otan la
situation des réfugiés devient plus
difficile avec la fermeture des
frontières entre le kosovo et l'albanie
l'aide humanitaire est parfois détournés
ou retardés comme nous l'avons constaté
en albanie les réfugiés kosovars
commencé à arriver en turquie en
allemagne en france et en italie
depuis je vous confirme le fait que
monsieur lionel jospin premier ministre
sera demain l'invité en direct de cette
édition de 20 heures dans quelques
secondes la météo avec isabelle martinet
et puis à une heure du matin le journal
de la nuit qui vous sera présentée par
laurence ostolaza demain à 7h50 dans les
4 vérités
marie pierre farkas recevra monsieur
charge jusqu'à le mini chargé de la
coopération à 13h vous retrouverez
rachid arhab à demain 20h bonsoir merci